Jacob, I'm just curious do you remember
the first time that you were recognized when you,
you know, coming into this big show
and the first time you got recognized
where were you and what happened?
Yeah, so I was on the subway in New York, this was only
this was season four, so only season three had aired.
And I was just sitting, minding my own business
[Conan] And where are you? You're...
I'm on the subway.
On the subway, okay.
I think I was heading towards Times Square.
I don't know if that's an important detail.
(Laughter)
Probably not.
I'm not a police officer, I'm just
(Laughter)
And yeah, all of the sudden I just heard
"(beep) Grey Worm."
(Laughter)
(Cheering)
I had my head down, my head was down,
and then it was like "What? What just happened?"
And I looked up and nobody was looking at me.
There was a guy that had a newspaper and it kind of,
I was like "It's you. You're not reading it.
"It's upside down." (beep)
Wait, he just quickly put up a newspaper?
That is so lame. He probably cut out the eyes
so he could be looking at you.